Yes?
I was just wondering what advice you would give young people who are considering careers as writers?
I guess we should buy your book.
Well, I think you ought to read a lot and I think you ought to write a lot.
And those are really the two major things; you can't put it off.
You have to really do the work.
You have to be well-read.
I don't have any patience with people who say,...
..."Oh man, I wanna be a writer but I don't have time to read."
But if you don't have time to read, you can't be a writer.
You've got to read just about everything.
So, I think that's the most important thing...
...and then you have to read.
I mean, you have to write in order to develop a style and create a style of your own.
When it comes to the reading part of it, there's a magic moment...
...a really magic moment.
If you read enough, it will always come to you if you wanna be a writer...
...where you put down some book and say, "This really sucked."
"I can do better than this."
"And this got published!"